una super huelga una mega huelga incluso
una huelga monstruosa estas son algunas
de las palabras que han utilizado los
medios de comunicación en Alemania para
describir la huelga a gran escala que
este lunes está paralizando
prácticamente todo el servicio de
transporte público en el país la amplia
mayoría de trenes de buses y de aviones
no están en funcionamiento como parte de
un reclamo sindical que busca el aumento
de los salarios para los trabajadores en
especial en momentos en que Alemania
está afectada por una alta inflación la
inflación en febrero llegó en Alemania
al 8.7% una cifra que para el país es
alta quienes apoyan la huelga aseguran
que es necesaria para poner presión
sobre los empleadores quienes rechazan
la huelga aseguran que es exagerada y
que está poniendo en problemas a
millones de personas que dependen del
transporte público para su vida
diaria se espera que en el transcurso de
la semana todo vuelva a su normalidad
que los servicios de transporte público
se restablezcan a medida que los
sindicatos y los empleadores se reúnen
para tratar de buscar una